[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui cécile
chabrot qui publie prof à l'archipel
c'est l'un des livres les plus drôles de
la rentrée et maryline martin qui sort
george jahn et joa aux éditions du
rocher à l'occasion du 40e anniversaire
de la mort de change brassens et sa
biographie amoureuse on va faire la
connaissance des deux femmes de sa vie
qui lui ont inspiré plusieurs de ses
chansons mais là on commence tout de
suite par vous cécile chabrot voici
l'image que vous avez choisie pour
illustrer notre époque ce sont vos
élèves et vous oui ce sont mes élèves
lors du dernier projet mémorielle que
j'ai menée je mène chaque année un
projet mémorielle justement pour pour
élargir ce qu'on fait on fait des choses
au sein de la classe on étudie des
textes vous apprendre le français ces
profs de français quand même voilà donc
donc on étudie d'aider des textes mais
aussi des images des supports sonores
et puis et puis idéalement je je je mène
avec eux des projets alors que ce soit
sur la shoah l'année dernière c'était
sur l'homme sur le soldat inconnu et
puis sur sur les gueules cassées voilà
et je suis très intéressé par la façon
dont ça se passe au début de l'année où
je vois par exemple j'avais fait mon
cours sur les gueules cassées évidemment
delcassé de la guerre de 14 ans tous
ceux qui sont revenus défiguré à
l'époque c'était terrible voilà est bon
évidemment je fais mon cours donc je
fais étudier un texte je montre des
photos une histoire de voile at un petit
peu de choquer et puis j'en vois qui
ricanent donc là je me dis il faut faire
quelque chose voilà et donc au fil de
l'année avec avec ce projet d'un ben
voilà la fin de l'année ils sont tous
sous l'arc genre de tenue il a recueilli
avec avec leurs tee shirt je peux pas
j'ai centenaire et puis fit entre temps
des longs ils ont fait une feinte de
réaliser un film
où ils ont incarné des gueules cassées
et je crois qu'à la fin il ya le respect
le respect du soldat et puis et puis
voilà ils ont ils ont
ils se sont ancrés dans les valeurs
républicaines et puis dans des valeurs
d'humanité de respect de tolérance
voilà alors les livres écrits par les
profs c'est un des mario l'un des
marronniers de du mois de septembre ils
ont eu 10 en général beaucoup de mal de
l'éducation nationale du métier qui se
perd des enfants qui sont tous devenus
des crétins et vous votre livre alors
c'est le contraire il était une fois
très drôle très gai très bien écrit vous
aimez de vos élèves en dépit de leur
faute d'orthographe et de leur ignorance
crasse voulait traiter de tous les noms
quand même mais vous ne changeriez pas
votre place pour quoi que ce soit au
monde de l'impression non non moi
évidemment l'éducation nationale est
très imparfaite ça c'est une évidence
mais je crois que bas dans ce livre
c'est en toile de fond c'est un prétexte
parce qu'effectivement merci d'avoir dit
que j'avais bien écrit très surtout
c'est surtout le le portrait de mes
élèves c'est vraiment un
coup de projecteur sur eux d'une
certaine façon c'est davantage un livre
sur l'adolescence et sur des adolescents
qui sont méconnus parce que c'est les
adolescents au sein de la classe et les
parents ne connaissent pas leurs enfants
au sein de la classe moi combien de fois
j'ai eu des parents qui m'ont dit ah
mais non mais il est pas du tout comme
ça à la maison tu m'étonnes m'étonne et
heureusement donc oui certains certains
se lâchent en classe et jamais ils ne
seraient comme ils sont à la maison et
puis d'autres au contraire sont très
épanouie chez eux et puis on les entend
pas en classe donc on a des ados
dans une relation tout à fait
particulière et voilà mon livre c'est çà
s'est
l'interaction que j'ai avec j bien que
j'aie parce que mon livre c'est un
c'était un livre autobiographique dont
je ne suis le porte-parole de personnes
je ne parle pas au nom des profs c'est
pas un manifeste jeu je me plains mais
c'est ce sont mes plantes c'est sont mes
doléances voilà et parce que je ne suis
surtout pas puis je veux pas rentrer
dans des polémiques ça ça m'intéresse
pas du tout cas un côté petit nicolas
mais mais le petit nicolas il était en
primaire là elle qu'ils sont au collège
et qu'on a l'impression que le niveau
est le même le petit nicolas c'était
vraiment les années 60 oui
non pas parfois effectivement on en est
pas loin mais non mais il ya quand même
des gars comme d'excellence et l'a20 oui
tout n'est pas perdu on les voit et on
les entend dans votre livre alors il
faisait alors que vous avez exercé
longtemps dans le département du 93 qui
est le département le plus pauvre de
france qui est réputation exécrable dans
votre profession
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans le 15e
arrondissement qui est un arrondissement
de l'ouest parisien à ces bourgeois pas
très loin d'ici
quelle différence
alors la différence ce serait peut-être
l'hétérogénéité parce que dans le 93 à
j'avais des classes où vous les profils
étaient relativement similaires
voilà je vais le dire un peu un peu
familièrement mais ils étaient tous en
galère bon là je me retrouve dans un
établissement dans lequel à côté de
gamins qui sont en difficulté j'ai des
fils de notables et d'une certaine façon
et je le dis dans le livre cette
hétérogénéité là est plus difficile à
gérer parce que les profils sont
tellement différents que
amener des élèves à aimer
toujours l'assommoir et zola on a
l'impression que je ne fais que ça bon
admettons aller rostand eh bien eh bien
c'est compliqué parce que les niveaux
sont les niveaux ne sont pas les mêmes
il y en a qui ont déjà sondé à faire de
pleins de connaissances qui passent leur
leur dimanche dans des musées et puis
avec les autres pas du tout cas une
émulation
alors ça je vais vous dire ça dépend des
classes 1 ça dépend des mayonnaises il
ya des mayonnaises ça fonctionne
parfaitement bien ça c'est il ya des
classes à une émulation effectivement
positive et c'est pour ça qu'on mélange
qu'on mélange au maximum les classes en
revanche quand on est dans une classe
dans lesquels les meilleurs sons sont
utic s'est laissé les moins bons qu'ils
prennent un qui prennent le pas et cette
ségrégation dont on parle de plus en
plus souvent vous y fait allusion à
plusieurs reprises dans le dans votre
livre selon la carte scolaire la
profession des parents est-ce que
fatalement on réussira moins bien où on
réussira mieux à l'école bah écoutez moi
moi je pense qu'on réussira moins bien
saurais pas trop vous dire à vrai dire
oui je sais pas trop c'est vous avez
fait six ans d'études de lettre 10 ans
de latin cinq ans de littérature
médiévale 50 politique historique c'est
nécessaire pour faire de la littérature
médiévale c'est de la linguistique
comparer pouvoir comprendre le français
du moyen âge c'est pas la porte à tous
les français d'aujourd'hui et vous vous
retrouvez face à des 6e dont vous dites
que à partir mélange l'alphabet à partir
de la lecture de la lettre elle est ce
que vous ça vous semble décourageant
passe quelque chose qui revient dans les
livres de profs c'est le découragement
vous à la pression quand on lit votre
livre s'est jamais découragé ah bah non
mais je ça ce serait
un livre c'est quand même vrai c'est
assez romance et c'est là il ya 22 ans
de pratique dans un livre de 200 pages
donc il ya forcément des moments où moi
aussi j'étais pas bien vous parle je
vais pas mentir néanmoins je pense qu'il
est important d'avoir fait des hautes
études pour pouvoir
villegats risée le savoir au mieux et le
transmettre au mieux voilà
je veux dire si je ne savais pas grand
chose je vous serais pas bonne devant le
ba-ba de l'utilisent pas intéressante
non mais à bonn ne s'est pas le mot
employé
[Rires]
très attendue elle sur le quai péri oui
oui et vous faites très attention aux
leurres vous l'aurez constitué assez
bien d'ailleurs lé crif qui est pas
forcément facile parce que c'est de
l'oral vincent guillaume et c'était 2
c'était que c'était le butin le but
c'était pas d'écrire quelque chose avec
un style classique ça je pense savoir le
faire mais ça ne restituaient absolument
pas l'atmosphère du collège
le côté vivant le côté multiculturel
voilà et le langage passe par là donc il
fallait absolument que leur langage soit
présent je voulais pas non plus tomber
dans la caricature maîtres du welsh rsa
toutes les lignes ça c'est pas du tout
intéressant c'est pour ça que j ai aussi
un style et ma prose ma connaissance de
la langue française et voilà c'est la
rencontre de ces deux univers c'est le
sait le mélange est tout à l'heure quand
vous montriez la photo de vos élèves
sous l'arc de triomphe dieu quand vous
les avez fait un travail avec eux sur
les gueules cassées que ça les avait
choqués j'ai l'impression que vous avez
bien choquer vous allez provoquer au
fond alors vous avez deux exemples qui
viennent dans le livre en le faisant
étudier la chevelure qui est une célèbre
nouvelle de maupassant sur un écran au
fil et en leur montrant l'origine du
monde le célèbre tableau de courbet
alors qu'est ce que vous obtenez avec ça
mais ils n'ont pas le monopole de la
provocation et c'est bien d'ailleurs
qu'il doit qu'ils veulent vous provoquez
tout le temps à tout le temps non parce
que la cei savent pas qu'ils ont
donc se met souvent on est bien sûr
évidemment mais mais justement par le
savoir je veux leur montrer qu'on peut
être aussi punchy et quand je leur
montre l'origine du monde avec
avec le sexe de femme grands ouverts
alors là moi je peux vous dire que c'est
là ils sont tous ceux catastrophé
choquer mais j'ai là gilbert dans une
motion à terme est belle et mais j'ai
déjà eu à la
quatrième je fais passer en sixième
contre claire mais ils vont évidemment
sur internet il voit du pays connaissent
ils connaissent tous hein donc donc
cette espèce de
d'hypocrisie qui me font marrer cc c'est
à mourir de rire quant à la quant à la
chevelure oui je commence en expliquant
ce qu'est la nécrophilie ce qui me
permet aussi de de parler de tout un tas
de demain je vais choquer mais c'est pas
si c'est pas grave c'est la kommandatur
c'est le vocabulaire ans quand on parle
de tout un tas de déviance sexuelle et
on explique voilà les racines des
racines grecques les racines latines
alors là c'est voilà ils sont ils sont
choqués mais en même temps je leur
montre aussi à quel point à quel point
la longue et belle quoi quel point la
l'étymologie c'est beaucoup et ce que ça
peut nous emmener et finissent par être
remporté aussi c'est ça l'argent quels
que soient les origines sociales bien
sûr bons mais ils sont en fait
ils sont sont tous pareils ça je le mets
dans ma quatrième de couverture parce
que j'y tiens
savez j'étais la dernière fois
j'attendais
j'étais dans ma voiture et j'étais
devant le le parvis d'un collège privé
et bien je peux vous dire que les gamins
du privé n'ont rien à enlever à envier
aux me rends tu les entends des ce
s'insulter se traiter de noms d'oiseaux
les mêmes les biens il ya on parle très
souvent de la violence qui monte chez
les enfants il ya une forme de guînes
certaine violence est en permanence que
contre laquelle vous êtes obligé de buts
est à la fois verbale et physique aussi
on a l'impression qu'on peut la contenir
vous y parvenez
à bas la violence comme on dire la
violence verbale oui parce que surtout
qu'il a la moitié des mots qu'ils
emploient ils n'en connaissent pas le
sens donc il balance comme ça et alors
si je mets cet exemple aussi dans le
livre quand je leur explique ce que
c'est qu'un con que c'est le sexe de la
femme alors d'un coup l'a7 à cette
insulte s'est terminé comme
voilà quand on aime on avait on avait
étudié avec les sixièmes la grenouille
qui se veut faire aussi grosse que le
boeuf et que je leur avais expliqué que
c'était ce qui était une chétive pécore
ils étaient tous contents en sortant
dans les couloirs de ce traité de paix
corps voilà donc deux étaient là dessus
moi je crois que j'étais petit je
n'utilise la paix que lorsqu'elle pays
oui oui mais voilà c'était c'est donc
c'est une insulte qui nous non il était
était très content une nouvelle insulte
alors alors ne partage pas de mares donc
c'était bien
alors dans votre livre tout n'est pas
rose vous vous parlez des moyens qui
manquent évidemment du nivellement par
le bas
de la bureaucratie du laxisme
c'est quoi les les pires ennemis des
profs d'après vous enfin de vous en tant
que prof alors deux mois mais vraiment
de moi donc les copains collègues on
s'excite passez moi
moi c'est l'allègement des programmes
parce que
je trouve que
priver les enfants de du savoir et de la
connaissance
c'est la pire chose qui soit voulait
dire pour pas les traumatiser
on va leur faire apprendre des textes de
rap plutôt que des fables de la fontaine
irait au delà de ça
moi je trouve qu'on leur fait de moins
en moins à prendre de choses quand je
vois alors là c'est pas ma matière mais
quand je vois les manuels d'histoire je
trouve ça de plus en plus pauvres et je
trouve ça bien dommage et du coup je
suis pas tellement étonné que dans
l'actualité on voit certaines certaines
choses qui sont assez déplorable quand
on voit d'aider
des gens contrôlent vaccin
comment dire défilé avec des étoiles
jaunes
bon là je me dis que il faut absolument
restituer la connaissance et donc le
respect parce que voyez c'est
extrêmement violent et irrespectueux
envers les victimes de la shoah et moi
il me savonne la planche ces gens là
parce que je je je fais des projets
mémorielle j'explique ce que c'est que
la shoah ce que c'est que la
discrimination ou même la discrimination
à outrance
et les manifestations c'est ça et on
confond tout est est ce que les parents
font partie de vos ennemis à volontaires
bien entendu mais
certains peut-être mais pas tous parce
que je il faut quand même voir et ça
aussi je le dis dans le livre il ya
certaines situations qui sont tellement
tellement complexe est tellement
difficile que
[Musique]
on ne peut pas toujours condamner les
parents moi je certaines situations je
sais pas comment moi même je ferai donc
non j'ai pas envie de j'ai pas envie de
c'est un peu facile de s'en prendre aux
parents et les réseaux sociaux alors on
va dire c'est un peu facile mais vous
vous dites que de laisser aller les
enfants de moins de 13 ans sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est criminel ouais son
rythme les pas non non je rigole pas non
c'est vrai je rigole pas et c'est vrai
que au sein de la famille
j'aimerais que les parents soient plus
vigilants
néanmoins vous savez je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de parents qui travaillent qui
sont pas forcément chez eux et je pense
que l'enfant il peut être au sein de sa
famille tout en y étant pas c'est à dire
passer toute une nuit sur les réseaux
sociaux est en fait il va être avec des
adultes les adultes de la société c'est
un des gens comme vous et moi
enfin vous et moi on parle bien
je me sens pas mais ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'ils vont se retrouver avec avec
des gens de la société est en fait je
pense que c'est les gens de la société
c'est la société tout entière qui
devrait davantage exemplaire parce que
quand on va sur les réseaux bon c'est un
peu poubelles quoi il voit là les les
exemples qu'on qu'on donne à nos jeunes
mais vous avez un de dire au fond que
quand on leur reproche leur ignorance
aux adolescents d'aujourd'hui on se rend
pas compte à quel point notre société
est intacte et manquent de culture bah
oui bah oui c'est pour ça que c'est pour
ça qu'on a énormément de travail mais
c'est c'est vrai que c'est un peu
désolant vous voyez moi j'ai mes
troisième cette année j'ai quatre heures
avec eux ces quatre heures de français
pour l'heure pour l'heure un culte et
tout ce que j'aimerais leur tout ce que
j'aimerais leur transmettre leurs
données c'est pas beaucoup donc
donc si ça aussi ça notre problème alors
vous n'êtes pas du genre dans le livre à
dire c'était mieux avant vous avez même
consacré un petit chapitre cette
question vous aussi vous avez été
d'adolescentes
n'est néanmoins en quoi qu'est ce qu'ils
savent mieux que nous alors elle a le
même âge qu'est ce qu'ils savent mieux
que nous
parce que cet accès et aux réseaux
sociaux et à l'information tous azimuts
depuis tributaires de la télévision de
leurs parents etc etc salle et ça peut
être le mais le pire comme le meilleur
moi je je les trouve j'ai trouv plus
courageux que nous voilà moi je
rencontre tellement de profils d'élèves
moi je les trouve très courageux je vois
je vois qui j'étais je vois qu'ils sont
je trouve qu'on est dans une société
abominable je trouve très courageux
d'évoluer d'évoluer dans cette société
voilà ils ont pas le choix non plus
n'ont pas le choix non non ils n'ont pas
le choix mais justement ils sont
d'une certaine façon ils sont méritants
sont méritants le laxisme que vous
dénoncez ça consiste très souvent à pas
lors de des devoirs parce que ça demande
tous
décrit vous dit d'ailleurs que les
sixièmes ne savent pas qu'une leçon ça
s'apprend qu'on leur a jamais dit qu'il
fallait la prendre donc ils découvrent
vous reprocher sauf si le fait que bon
les faits peur doublé non plus que ça
coûte trop cher et que là aussi on veut
pas les traumatiser
que on leur fait apte rien apprendre par
coeur
on leur fait pâlir les classiques ce que
vous faites vous etc etc c'est ça le
lexique challenge là je veux dire c'est
comment dire un peu généralisés parce
qu'il ya quand même je te tiens à le
dire
il ya des professeurs des écoles qui
font bien leur travail mais mais
d'autres moins et oui j'aimerais bien
qu'on soit vraiment tous à être dans un
haut niveau d'exigence
parce que fin justement pour les pour
les aider pour les aider à
affronter affronter la société et vous
savez moi je suis professeur de français
je leur apprends à lire les textes je
leur apprends à lire les images je leur
apprends à lire les signes je leur
apprends à lire aussi à lire les hommes
à se lire les uns les autres et je crois
que tout le monde feint tous les tous
les enseignants doivent doivent
agir de cette façon mais mais sans
relâche et avec conviction avec avec
envie avec détermination
on est beaucoup à le faire a encore une
fois
vraiment il ya déjà dédé des gens de au
sein de l'éducation nationale qui ne qui
ne compte pas qui ne comptent pas leur
temps qu'ils ne comptent pas leur
énergie qui ne comptent pas leur argent
parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
mais voilà haïti ce qui se donne à fond
voilà c'est leur apprenez à écrire aussi
je me suis toujours demandé si
l'orthographe et et dieu sait si
l'orthographe est catastrophique
aujourd'hui vous si vous nous fait rire
aussi d'ailleurs sur cette question de
dans votre livre
mais je me demande est ce que
l'orthographe c'est si important le
vocabulaire c'est important plus on a de
cabu l'air plus on va arriver à penser
et avec 30 mots de vocabulaire on pense
pas loin avec 3000 mots de vocabulaire
on pense beaucoup plus loin déjà avec
30000 encore plus loin mais
l'orthographe est ce que c'est si
important que ça parce que vous vous
avez là de le regretter à l'époque quand
vous étiez jeune vous le dites dans
votre livre une faute d'orthographe
c'était trois points ce groupe i
maintenant surtout faut rien dire parce
que ça valait traumatisés
est ce que vous êtes sûr que
l'orthographe c'est si important que ça
vous savez moi je crois qu'en fait je
suis de la vieille école je de la
vieille école et et j'estime que la
langue française est trop belle pour que
pour pourquoi enfreignent les règles et
je trouve que c'est important
d'apprendre des règles
aussi ça donne de cette de la méthode ça
donne une certaine discipline voilà et
il ya une esthétique aussi vous bâti
sommes habitués à la bonne orthographe
quand on voit un mot mal orthographié ça
me choque et ça me fait saigner les u21
au fond tout bienveillante que je suis
je suis obligé de pointer un c'est
évident
bon après il
faudrait justement voir s'il ya des
études qui montrent que
peut-être qu'on peut peut-être qu'on
peut
être très très très fort sans connaître
veut bien s'en maîtrisez bien les règles
d'orthographe bon
alors y aller mais juste juste pour
l'esthétique mais quand même c'est y
aller les pointes vocabulaire aussi par
maman vous leur faites et étudiés ne me
quitte pas la chanson de jacques brel et
la conclusion et c'est d'élèves et des
chèques brain c'était un sacré canard
niveau en tout cas moi je n'ai pas
compris ce que c'était qu'un canard vous
avez fini par la pensée et puis non mais
je vais vous dire mais c'est vrai c'est
là que c'est absolument génial parce que
ils me disent à jacques brel c'est un
canard naturellement
moi je me retrouve complètement
complètement
démunis donc j'essaie de faire genre
mais ça ne faut surtout pas faire genre
donc un moment vaut mieux dire je ne
sais pas donc j'ai essayé j'ai raté
donc non je ne savais pas ce qu'était un
canard ils me l'ont appris donc ouais
mon dieu c'est un mec il est soumis
l'image 1 donc bon effectivement vu
comme ça jacques brel est un canard dont
je ne me quitte pas d'ordre ne le quitte
pas oui clairement mais savez que j'ai
géré j'ai regarder dans le dictionnaire
est en définitive le canard
être un canard sait courtisé une femme
de manière servile mais finalement ils
n'ont rien appris que j'allais leur
disons rien inventé mais c'est simple
rien inventé voilà et donc mais c'est
comme pour carotter a carotté une fois
une vidéo est madame dumas carottes et
toi moi je dis mais tu sais que tu sais
que tu es en train d' employer un mot
qui date du xviiie siècle mais je t'en
félicite
ça c'était à mourir de rire ils n'ont
absolument pas conscience des mots
qu'ils emploient et l ier il ya un
moment que moi je trouve absolument
extraordinaire dans votre livre c'est
pourtant un moment un peu grave puisque
c'est après l'assassinât des
dessinateurs de charlie hebdo vouloir
expliquer ce qui s'est passé et ensuite
vous leur dites maintenant on va
observer une minute de silence et il ya
quelqu'un qui vous dit aller où vous
dites commencé à aider ou dubawi
pour l'observer elle est où oui c'est le
genre de petit de petits événements ne
se fait pas de l'humour ah non c'était
très sérieux
ils cherchaient des oueds et la minute
de silence qui montre c'est ce qui
montre là les lacunes les lacunes du
vocabulaire alors maintenant c'est très
beau ça ressemble à du raymond devos
c'est très beau c'est très beau mais
enfin bon c'est quand même pas assez
beau pour que je lis or donc après ça a
été un travail sur la polysémie des mots
quand même c'était ce que nécessaire
mais oui on
a chacun risque passe quelque chose
chaque heure ça qui est formidable je
pense que c'est un tel tonneau des
danaïdes que moi je peux je peux mettre
en place leur jeu peut commencer le
deuxième tome avec les sixièmes vous
avez un moyen là aussi ça les choque
beaucoup vous appeler leur mère en live
ça lui aussi stanco alors il faut
l'expliquer qu'est ce que c'est quand
vous dites j'appelle ta mère en laye d'
abbey ça va je le fais avec les systèmes
mais je fais avec tout le monde en fait
parce que ça ça marche ça marche
divinement bien
vous avez un élève qui fait un petit peu
le qui fait un petit peu le kéké dans la
classe je suis dit bon écoute a très
bien donc j'ai pris soin en amont de
regarder le nom de sa mère et je lui dis
bah écoute a très bien je dis n'importe
quoi je vais appeler josette appelons-la
josette j'appelle josette en live et là
d'un coup silence de mort et je crois
que ce serait se serait pas pire si je
l'avais insulté d'ailleurs ramdam et e
vous avez le dit toumba mère l'attend
s'il te plait je n'ai pas insulté c'est
le nom de ta mère oui mais quand même et
là d'un coup plus personne mais c'est
l'idée de téléphoner à la mer aussi qui
a l'air de les terroriser ah oui mais
alors en plus en direct j'ai déjà fait
un en plus voilà c'est ça c'est que j'ai
ce que je dis je le fais il faut pas
rester dans la menace ça c'est un
conseil pour les jeunes profs jamais
menacé vous faire donc moi je sors mon
téléphone sur mon bureau pour regarder
l'heure
si ça va pas pas de problème j'appelle
josette et là d'un coup
il faut pas crier il faut trouver des
petites des petites astuces qui
va la cie qui vont une qui vont faire
naître un respect
papa pas éternelle parce que ça il faut
toujours renouvelé mais ça ça c'est ça
c'est sympa c'est sympa jusqu'au moment
où un élève je sache c'est l'histoire
suivante donc moi j'arrive tout fier
jean bouin qui me fait n'importe quoi et
je lui dis bah écoute
j'appelle maria amelia en live et là il
me regarde avec ses grands yeux mais qui
maria amelia déjà je commence à
redescendre un peu mieux mais c'est qui
s'y met c'est amer non mais ma mère ces
mamans voilées lassées laisser ce genre
de 2,2 comme on dire de petit événement
aussi de petites anecdotes qui fait et
lui d'un coup mais je le regarde mes
jeux font parce que et tout est comment
dire le ballon et je ne connais pas le
mot tiens voilà que ça ça retombe tout
retomber le soufflé retomber et puis
l'ambiance est bonne parce que du coup
tout le monde rigole et voyez vous ça
s'appelle profs et ça vient de paraître
l archipel ces signes et cécile chabot
merci ccim merci on fait une pause et on
se retrouve juste après avec maryline
martin
[Musique]
en octobre ce sera le centenaire de la
naissance de georges brassens et le 40e
anniversaire de sa mort le 29 octobre
1981 il avait 60 ans tout juste mme
aline martin vous en profitez pour
publier george jahn et joie aux éditions
du rocher vous allez nous raconter
qu'ils songent à n'est jamais d'abord
voici l'image qui symbolise le mieux
notre époque qu'à vos yeux qu'est ce
qu'elle représente pour vous mascelli
père cyber enfin tout ce qui tourne
autour des réseaux sociaux internet etc
tout tout tout cette époque connectés
hyperconnecté peut rien faire sans voilà
sans être liés à ces machines et ça ça
m'ennuie un petit peu il ya dieu sait si
ça a créé tout ça le une crise dans les
maisons de disques mais je me souviens
de georges brassens à l'époque il y
avait les petite cassette audio avec
lesquels on copiait les disques et il
était à des seuls à l'époque qui
disaient bah oui c'est comme ça à
tampico piles et disent que tant pis on
touche pas d'argent mais subissent et la
huent serrer la vis mais ceux ci disent
que c'est drôle je vais rebondir aussi
lorsqu'il rend visite lorsqu'il est
alité il est hospitalisé parce qu'il
fait des coliques néphrétiques et yahi
simon qui vient de rendre lui rend
visite avec je crois qu'ils avaient
raymond devos et il avait un walkman et
georges brassens était très intéressé
par cette nouvelle technologie donc ici
on va lui offrir le walkman
georges brassens
ou plutôt george jahn et joie c'est le
titre de votre livre say never j'en ai
marre oui georges brassens non pardon
oui c'est vrai que j'allais le dire mal
brassens jeanne et joa pardonnez moi
c'est pas une biographie ce serait
plutôt une carte du tendre vous dites ça
passe pas une énième biographie je vois
pas l'intérêt de répéter ce qui a déjà
été dit maintes fois moi je voulais
accès
le livre sur deux femmes les deux femmes
qui ont inspiré aussi son oeuvre jeanne
celle qui l'a qui l'a accueilli de 40 à
l'est pendant après juste après le st lô
144,44 et il disait d'elle d'ailleurs si
si je là si je la quitte je la tue 1 et
puis joaquin était qu'il aimait comme
une plainte et qui arrive dans sa vie en
47 donc c'est un amour caché au début et
qui va qui va l'accompagner jusqu'à la
note finale alors là on voit
effectivement l'article qui accompagne
la au moment où la mort de jeanne jeanne
tout le monde la cause et parce qu'il
est tellement de chansons qui parlent et
jonway donc la can de jeunes mais
georges brassens là elle est très âgé
alors il faut comprendre qu'il la
rencontre quand il a 19 ans et ça vient
d'arriver à paris georges brassens et 19
ans en 1940 pourquoi il a quitté cette
d'abord et pourquoi il vient habiter à
paris chez sachets attente alors qu'il
sait pas ce qu'il a il il a participé en
faisant le guet à des vols de bijoux et
ils écopent de prison mais avec sursis
mais seulement la famille est entachée à
honte de voilà de cette exaction et
georges file à paris chez la tante
toinette qui habite rue d'alésia qui
connaît très bien parce qu'il a fait
aussi au paravent des séjours dans la
capitale et lattes antoinette ludier
couteau quelques chutes accueil mais il
va falloir travailler moi je vais pas te
nourrir à rien faire donc il va
commencer à faire des petits boulots
comme relayeur et puis va finir à dans
l'usiné l usine renault mais latente one
est elle elle fait faire des ses habits
auprès d'une couturière qui s'appelle
jeanne qui habite juste en face de la
rue d'alésia lowell l'habite petit tapas
jana l'habitant l'impasse florimont et
jeanne et georges ça va faire tilt au
début du fait qu'il ya trente ans de
plus que malone donc elle est là la
carotte devant quand elle a 40 ans et
elle habite dans cet endroit non c'est
pas aujourd'hui il ya maintenant une
plaque dès que tu n'as pas se faire
décrivez là parce que c'est là qu'il va
venir habiter en 44 il est il a été
mobilisé pour le service du travail
obligatoire en allemagne il y est allé
et puis là pas envie d'y retourner
profite d'une une main ou des quinze
jours de permission il dit non je veux
pas je parvenir il veut pas non plus à
l'est dans la résistance parce que
souvent dans les maquis c'était les
réfractaires aux os et aux pluies non il
est pacifiste chansons célèbres les deux
ans qu'il celui qui aimait les anglais
celui du point fr il est au top pour lui
mais sur le même pied exactement non
liveu évolué il veut créer des chansons
c'est tout ce qui l intéresse et donc où
il va s'il va se réfugier mais là la
basse allait elle est propre là les
jolis noms en 40 1,44 elle est cachée on
la voit pas aller elle est vraiment
enclavé dans les maisons un peu sordide
et c'est un véritable clock il n'y a pas
de gaz électricité il n'y a pas d'eau
c'est là que vit jeanne et l'accueil
quand il veut pas retourner au st lô il
va se cacher là alors comme elle est
déjà sa maîtresse c'est tout est parfait
oui elle est mariée elle est mariée elle
s'est mariée pendant pendant le service
de charges à basdorf à marcel marcel
planche qui est un gentil monsieur qui
va lui a inspiré d'abord l'auvergnat sur
sol de verre bien c'est lui voilà mais
il était pas gnangnan il était pas né en
auvergne mars à lille était né à brie
comte robert
l'auvergnat ça peut être marcel mais ça
peut être aussi le bougnat qui justement
leur faisait don de quelques quelques
charbon pour pour alimenter le feu parce
qu'il est rien c'est un dénuement total
lorsqu'elle n'est pas de charbon ont
brûlé quand même le parquet de la patrie
- faut savoir 1 et c'est un véritable
bouge mais ils sont contents puis toute
façon george il disait qu'il aimait
vivre il avait un sens de l'inconfort
donc il était bien à la alors ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'il arrive dans
cette impasse en 1944 pour se cacher et
il n'en repartira jamais il va y vivre
22 ans en dépit du fait qu'ils sera
devenu une énorme vedette
avec beaucoup d'argent il va continuer
vivre avec jal enfin à côté de jade et
vous l'avez dit pas ce qu'il dit là t'es
pas double si je mens d'alès et naturel
oui celle-là tu mets ont l'amour l'amour
tout court a remplacé à l'ailé devenue
la gêne de la chanson la mère
universelle ses cheveux ont blanchi sa
peau c'est par celle plus haut mais très
c'est comme une seconde maman elle
remplace l irak est resté à sète mais
effectivement il ya toujours cet
attachement et puis il est bien là on
lui fout la paix il est tranquille dans
son impasse ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a
fait installer le gaz les traverser avec
ses premiers que je suis avec ses
premiers reviendra voilà mais il faut
comprendre que jeune c'est sa première
fan aussi c'est là qu'il écrit ses
premières chansons et elle elle
encourageait les persuader va réussir
mais elle elle sait qu'elle a trouvé une
pépite elle et elle est folle de ceux de
georges d'ailleurs il répète ses
premières chansons dans la cour devant
jeanne et marcel et si son premier
public et elle les encourage à lui dit
mais tu vas y arriver vas-y fonce alors
elles l'encouragent à voir c'est un peu
ambivalent parce que quand il va
connaître le succès elle va être jalouse
tu vas dans le même qui connaissent le
succès il rencontre une autre femme née
en 1947 il rencontre jura il est
surnommé à pubs cochonnes et tout le
monde connaîtra püppchen un jour moi
quand j'étais enfant je me souvenais de
ceux de ce sobriquet püppchen voilà on
va la découvrir
véritablement en photo au moment de 2 à
la fin l'armée en 80 lors d'une escale
au languedoc une émission qu'il a tourné
ce que raconte en détail de la dernière
émission animée par evelyne pagès et là
ils sont sur la plage de sète avec
option et pulsion qui la rencontre 47
elle est mariée le 6 mai là un petit
garçon je vous dit il préfère l'amour
dans l'adultère au fond des bois
georges brassens il n'a pas envie de
comment dire de s'embarrasser de femmes
qui veulent faire des enfants fait il
n'a pas envie d'enfant lui ses enfants
ce sont ses chansons et il dit toujours
qu'il préfère aller cueillir les pommes
dans le verger voisins les pommes
abandonnée et qu'elle qu'elle tombe dans
le dans le pré il saura s'en servir
avant qu'elles ne pourrissent faire pour
résumer donc ils préfèrent aller voilà
et d'ailleurs elle tombe en cents au
bout de quelques mois ouais elle lui
propose de le garder il veut pas non il
veut pas alors ça ça toujours été
susurré jeu ça a été dit lors d'une
interview sur france inter il ya très
longtemps dans les années 70 georges les
bugs avec beaucoup de pudeur moi je les
remercie pour repris avec beaucoup de
pudeur dans mon livre mais il lui fait
la promesse de ne pas de ne pas
redemander voilà de fer 7 cette
sollicitation plus tard à une autre
femme parce que pub chaîne est âgé de 10
ans par neuf ans et demi de plus que
jorge il a toujours aimé les femmes plus
âgées que lui oui
c'est comme ça ça m'appartient pas et au
même moment deux qu'ils rencontrent
püppchen mais il vit toujours au crochet
de gênes gilad dans la dans l'impasse
florimont et est-ce qu'il y avait erreur
de la jalousie entre les deux femmes
alors elles se connaissent à elles
connaissent leur existence elles ne se
sont jamais rencontrés jeanne l'appelle
la surnomme ton petit pot à tabac sont
estonienne et
joa joie pubienne ll lui en veux un
petit peu parce qu'il a toujours jeanne
à la bouche et jeanne parfois pour pour
éviter que gens qui se rendent à ces
rendez vous amoureux parce qu'elle est
pas folle à lui cachant tuniques
pantalons donc donc il ya juste c'est
pourtant deux jours que l'on voit là
c'est sûr simple pantalon c'est son seul
pantalon
physiquement il est un peu à la norme
parce qu'il a les cheveux longs il ne va
jamais chez coiffeur il prend une
allumette
voit la coupe ses cheveux avec un beau
d'allumettes voilà et oui ressemble
ville un corps il a une tête de gitans
sur un corps de bûcheron il a vraiment
l'air de vagabond autant quand il arrive
à paris il est plutôt dans dit oui après
c'est vraiment le vagabond
manager n'est pas dans les normes et
c'est elle c'est un peu ça aussi qui a
inspiré sa chanson la mauvaise
réputation oui voilà donc il est il hors
les coûts mais c'est pas son c'est pas
son
il n'est pas en vue il n'y a pas envie
d'être à la mode lui c'est ce faire des
chansons alors il vivra jamais avec pub
chaîne même quand elle aura divorcer
ouais sévit pas sous le même toit parce
qu' il aime la femme dans son mystère il
n'aime pas être au quotidien avec une
femme parce que il dit qu'il n'a pas
besoin d'assister à ces abus sion pour
la découvrir pour les murs alors 1952
c'est la révélation je repasse ainsi
devient une véritable vedette tout le
monde est à genoux devant lui vous dire
il est très original à ce moment là est
celle qui va permettre de le faire
connaître la voix lasse et patachou
quelle époque une chanteuse très connue
qui non seulement va enregistrer ses
premières chansons mais en plus
l'emmener avec lui elle en tournée à huy
en belgique à la haie et là évidemment
il ya une histoire d'amour entre les
deux
pôles une troisième voilà une troisième
et puis bah oui comme cupidon a tiré sa
flèche et il sait pas quoi faire donc
choisi la chanson parce que c'est ce
qu'il veut faire donc
exit zhan exit jo à pâte à choux bata
shoe grand dans la drôme dans la danse
et ils vont rester un ensemble à leur
joie va mordre sur sa chique jane va
faire des crises de folie d'ailleurs on
l'appelle la folle de l'impasse 1 et
mais lui continue alors ils envoient des
cartes postales pour tenir informés
c'est de ces deux dames mais lady de la
tournée court parce que patachou va être
appelé en aux états unis faire une
tournée est elle si elle préfère sa
carrière et il va lui offrir un petit
s'habiller et lui dire à ben écoute
quand tu y aura assez de tourner ce
sablier ce directeur a tu ne m'auras
plus attendus et
ça sera fini hélas ce volet il revient
alors chez jeanne toute façon qu'ils
habitent mais chez le jeu et il arrive à
reconquérir jeu ça va pas être facile
mais oui mais jo a essayé à la divorcée
elle est libre comme l'air dont cavale
le faire un petit peu lanterner et
bayrou il va retrouver jo à qui va
assister dans l'ombre dans la paix non
alors il disait je ne suis pas dans son
nom que je suis dans sa lumière mais
elle était toujours placé en concert
toujours dit dit ravet enfin voila si
c'est bien bien loin de la scène est
d'ailleurs il lui avait dit le jour où
je serai connu tu seras tu seras
emmerder vraiment cette question son
terme et donc voila mais elle l'a elle
assistait le suivait dans ses tournées
ouais alors le jour il est connu on se
rend compte qu'il plaît énormément aux
femmes oui georges boit ça c'est une
sorte de sex symbol dans les années
savent aller ou pas oui mais et vous le
raconter les femmes sont prêtes à
n'importe quoi les jeux quand je raconte
l'anecdote de la femme qui s'est enfermé
nu dans un dans le coffre de sa voiture
ce qui lui a pas du tout plu mais
vraiment pas parce que il avait il était
pudique un genre est un saint il y avait
aussi des femmes qui il ya une anecdote
d'une femme qui devient le lavoir le
voir dans sa loge et qui lui dit fais
moi un enfant et ça y est j'ai calculé
les dates sont bonnes il faut que tu me
fasses un enfant et georges lui dit mais
attend avec tu as vu l'âge que j'ai on
pourrait faire qu'un brouillon
[Rires]
est-ce qu'il va rester fidèle
fidèle à ses deux femmes oui oui
politiquement on lui connaît pas
d'autres histoires aux fonds non mais
moi ça m'intéressait pas de savoir plus
non c'est pas c'était brut moi je
voulais me remettre en lumière
l'histoire de ces deux femmes qui
avaient inspiré son oeuvre et qui avait
été acquitté même si jeanne est devenue
la mère universelle comme tu disais tout
à l'heure elle était vraiment elle l'a
pris par la main il sait très bien ce
qui lui devait et d'ailleurs il le
disait jusqu'au bout jusqu'à 80 il
visait méjanes je lui dois tout
ils étaient très amoureux d'elle au
début il est jeune il a 30 ans de plus
que lui mais il est très bon quand il
part
il revient sur cette quitte paris avec
le flot des réfugiés encore ans 40 il
lui écrit en cachette et ils lui
demandent d'ailleurs quand il appelle ma
jeannette il créera une chanson cap a
été publiée pour maje net et il lui
demande de décrire depuis qu'elle lui
réponde chez son ami henri del pont à 7
ouais c'est une idylle alors quand il va
commencer à gagner de l'argent ce qui
est très rapide puisqu'il son succès est
immense à ce moment là bas les premiers
qu'on profite c'est jeanne et marcel son
mari puisqu'il va installer l'eau
l'électricité va réunir les deux les du
monde les deux aux appartements mitoyens
il ya un appartement mitoyen à l'impasse
là là là mais voilà il va réunir ses
deux appartements pour n'en faire qu'un
et je l'avais qu'il rachète et a par
contre pour qu'ils aient plus de loyer à
payer exactement marcel va pouvoir vivre
une retraite tranquille lui achète un
vélo lui dis allez hop premier dans le
quartier et puis ça fera du bien et tu
va maintenant te poser jeanne peut se
faire soigner ce qu'elle était quand
même su comme une indigente on y vivait
de rien il ya elle faisait les fins de
marché de la rue d'alésia il faisait
même alors en présentant il disait
l'applet fait quelques passes pour
preuve à tossiat le quotidien mais oui
ils vont avoir une vie un petit peu plus
bourgeoise mais bon c'est pas tellement
leur truc non plus et alors il va il va
collectionner les maisons lui qui n'aura
pas de logement autre que chez jeanne
jusqu'en 1966 il va s'acheter une maison
en bretagne on va la voir il ya une
maison à christian invisible voilà dans
les yvelines aussi d'abord ça c'est la
maison les yvelines et le moulin de la
bombe dans les yvelines où il a il fera
que des trous en fait comme de son père
était maçon il adorait ça et il paraît
qu'il fallait redéfinir ses amis disait
que il passait son temps il l'embauché
les copains la bande de cons comme il
les appelait à faire des trous pour
faire voilà pour faire des travaux dans
cette maison et il va l'abandonner parce
qu'un jour il va s'apercevoir que les
chambres à côté ont été vendus à des
promoteurs et il a dit je sais plus 1000
tondeuse à gazon en même temps c'est pas
possible j'ai pas pour ainsi la maison
bretagne aussi qui est très joli et
kadrige est au bord de la mer on la voit
la belle a été le cas vendus a pas très
longtemps d'ailleurs à kerflandry pas
très loin de paimpol alors là il va
rejoindre ses copains au café de
l'univers à paimpol et oui là on dit
qu'il va prendre quelques uns gay il
ferait refait le monde avec avec des
gens du cru et on lui fout la paix c'est
d'ailleurs il se dit on l'appelle le
cousin est le cousin de paris il est
tranquille jo à ses hortensias il est là
son petit jardin ils sont peinards oui
là il quand même il admet qu'elle vienne
avec lui en vacances ils partagent pas
la même chambre est-ce que tout va bien
même ils partagent pas là mais non parce
que georges brassens est à l'habitude de
se lever aux aurores à 5 heures du matin
il garde son île à un quotidien bien
bien régence et voilà donc à 5h01 soleil
il y a plus les cris et j'aime c'est une
couche tard donc elle elle regarde les
émissions traitant et vous raconter
d'ailleurs que quand il est là bobino à
paris
quand il sort de scène il va embrasser
jeunes oui parce qu'elle l'attend et oui
c'est le rituel il pourrait très bien
faire à défaire la bamboche avec ses
amis et rejoindre dans les bras de joie
même pas non non et ils passent par la
chambre de jeanne il embrasse elle
l'attend dormir ouais ouais c'est mignon
et sa jeanne là où elle est tout à fait
surprenante c'est que
1966 elle a 75 ans elle rencontre un
autre genre à ce moment elle est veuve
marcel blanchet est décédé et elle se
remarie mais oui parce qu'elle est toute
seule elle a lui dit d'ailleurs mais
georges qui m'a abandonné toi tu es tout
le temps tourne et moi je m'ennuie tout
seul un passe donc voilà pour passer le
temps elle va au café avenue du maine
pas très loin et à la rencontre il faut
savoir concilier en france à cette
époque là il ya des énormément de sosie
de george brassens tout le monde se fait
pousser la moustache est très tendance
et elles rencontrent cet homme
qui est né dans le 14e arrondissement
qui s'appelle georges sans jacques qui
va lui faire la cour qui va lui a fait
rire des lunettes de soleil des jolis
foulards et cetera mais qui va leur
bobine et parce que ce genre changea que
c'est un ivrogne notoire et qui a fait
plusieurs séjours dans en asile
psychiatrique
et quand george lui revient de tourner
il il le retrouve la voilà donc il reste
pas là il est le sosie ne restent pas
dormir le soir mais il vient clamer
sa colère sous les fenêtres de georges
en disant voilà enfin su en l'insultant
et georges perd sa quiétude il est pas
bien et il va essayer de demander à
jeanne ne pas se marier avec ce fameux
georges mais peine perdue jeanne voilà
son grain de folie encore et elle va se
marier avec clichy donc en 1966 à 75 ans
elle épouse ce jeune homme un milliard
en mobylette avec le perroquet dans une
cage attaché a enfin lié aux à la taille
de ce nouveau georges en bretagne pas
chez georges mois sachez d'ailleurs et
là à ce moment là je vois ça celui des
ménages quitte la patrie monde et est
alors il va s'installer pas très loin
dans le 14e arrondissement dans un
immeuble moderne qui s'appelle le
méridien c'est ça oui il a pour voisin
jacques brel c'était exactement et c'est
très bien parce que céline l'immeuble
vraiment alors l'accès d'immeubles
modernes des années 60 typique il existe
des ascenseurs très moderne très 70 ans
fait aussi 60 70 et oui et donc il va y
rester quelques temps mais il va
demander à son secrétaire particulier
pierre étienne oteniente qui édite
gibraltar comme il l'appelait de lui
trouver à un endroit une petite maison
un peu plus tranquille pour qu'ils
puissent composer parce que là il a
toujours peur d'ennuyer les voisins etc
donc il va aller ben rue santos dumont
dans le 15e arrondissement
ouais très loin après le décès jeanne
d'ici et pas très loin de chez jeanne
non plus jeune qui va mourir en 68 dont
deux ans après son mariage il est à son
chevet et et le mari est à son chevet
aussi oui mais ils s'ignorent
superbement
il georges brassens l'a toujours qu'il
appelait le fou parce que georges
brassens donner des sobriquets à tout le
monde donc lui c'était le fou donc ils
l'ignorent et quand ils rentrent pour
faire 1-1 détails sur sur joie et sur
leur rivalité commune n'a jamais joie
voix soit son georges dépité est
vraiment très très attristé et elle lui
dit elle est morte et il lui répond
combien coûte si c'est pas le cas c'est
bien imiter
ils vont il lui reste treize ans à vivre
genre croissance donc on va dire il ne
vit pas avec joie mais là à ce moment là
il ya plus qu elle ya plus qu elle c'est
la femme de dix clair sur sur son lit
quelques jours avant de mourir georges
brassens lui demandera de l'épouser et
elle ne profitera pas à lui dit non
couton à jour via qu'il avait gribouillé
la demande célèbre chanson la non
demande en mariage donc on ce qu'il est
plutôt content c'est ça et fidèle
justement à ses principes et à lui à lui
dit non on a été heureux on a été
heureux ensemble et lui il savait qu'il
était malade qu'il était condamné mais
il pensait qu'il aurait un peu plus de
temps et
mais bon il à la mort l'a rattrapé
effectivement vous raconter en détail sa
dernière année ouais
en fait mon livre se passant à la halle
à lézardrieux en est en outre 80 c'est
les dernières vacances du chanteur et on
l'accompagnent sur cette plage de
lézardrieux mais aussi dans son
quotidien en bretagne et ses prétextes
effectivement as com ont fait était en
feu y est un album de photos ces
prétextes à rentrer dans sa vie dans sa
vie de chanteur mais dans sa vie d'homme
aussi il va y veille jo sera enterrée
avec lui oui
piquionne va être enterré auprès de de
son éternel greluche ont comme elle
l'appelait son éternel amoureux et ouais
ils passent tous les deux leur mort en
vacances à à 7 et jamais temps
d'enterrer web elle est à bagneux je
suis allé lui dire
bonjour l'autre jour avec marcel planche
ils sentiraient tous les deux dans un
soutien de manioc la trompette entretenu
il ya un joli coeur en pierres posées
sur sept et lui est enterré à 7 mais pas
dans le cimetière des riches non
cimetière du pis qui s'appelait le
cimetière des pauvres ou deux 10 le
ramassis est d'ailleurs là où est
enterré paul valéry dans le cimetière
des riches avec nicolas murray existe
sur la mer il ya un panneau en dix ans
la tente de charger enfin ce n'est pas
ici voilà mais c'est drôle est ce qu'il
ya vraiment vécu georges brassens on a
apprécié alors peut-être parce que vous
dé raconter en détail la fin de sa vie
il donc on le voit religieusement tout
ce qui l'intéresse c'est ses chansons
cela voilà c'est et
mais il a vécu le reste de sa vie ou au
fond il était très monomaniaque dans ses
habitudes d'un livre et j'ai beaucoup lu
sur le sujet je les écoutais j'ai écouté
les bandes son et tout parce que je sais
pas c'est pas voilà j'ai pas fait ce
livre comme ça à l'avant vol mais non
c'est il est pas d c'est pas un homme
gay en fait il est il aime faire rire en
fait il ya plein de copains sa bande de
potes la bande de con mais c'est pas un
homme gay quand il est tout seul le pub
sienne le dit d'ailleurs il est très
introverti il est
pas son temps il y beaucoup il réécrit
l'écrit mais il est très taciturne il
est pas c'est pas un type vraiment je
vois c'est pas joyeux drilles il c'est
un pessimiste il et puis plus le temps
passe plus les gens qu'il aimait son
parti il à cette interrogation aussi par
rapport à ce qui se passe derrière 1
dans l'au delà dans l'au delà tucson
était très attaché aux forces de
l'esprit elle était aussi très intuitive
et lui c'est pas et ils se posent
beaucoup de questions alors il a déjà
des amis qu'ils sont religieux il alla
l'abbé duval
mais voilà c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'interrogations beaucoup
d'introspection je sais pas répondre à
sa place dans ses chansons il est un
véritable anarchiste un vrai libéral
libertaire ou est-ce qu'il l'est dans la
vie aussi on al impression puisqu'il n'a
pas aucun sens de la propriété amoureuse
alors pas du tout me l'apprend la
propriété tout court quand quand ils
commencent à être connues il ya un
prisonnier qui vient le voir eli sort de
prison et il lui tape de l'argent et
georges va lui donner et ce monsieur
reviendra quelques temps enfin quelques
années plus tard pour lui remettre il
lui dira mais non non pour lui rendre la
produire entre la somme prêtée et
georges brassens non lui dit non c'était
un cadeau il est très très généreux
c'est un peu la propriété c'est le vol
kwal pour lui un il est tout à fait il
n'est pas du tout attachés voilà on peut
pas l'imaginer avec de l'argent geof
passage ne sait pas pourquoi pour moi je
n'allais pas de chéquier c'est gibraltar
qui gérait son argent il
savait même pas quand quand il habitait
les gens un jour il se retrouve à
inviter les gens à prendre un verre il
laisse un pourboire alors comme il dit
ainsi je laisse rien on va croire que je
suis
voilà
le pam douala et sinon je vais laisser
trop et on accroche jeudi dilapide mon
argent par les fenêtres non il est pas
il n'est pas là dedans lui c'est vrai
c'est son oeuvre ses chansons sa lecture
sont son quotidien c'est
faire du sport aussi s'était installé un
vélo comme il pouvait pas faire
d'égalité reconnus donc il s'était
installé un vélo sur
vélo d'appartement vélo d'appartement et
voilà il est très très très casanier le
monde qui vient à lui bien piot
médailles et des appartements des
maisons à tout le monde il a été très
généreux oui très généreux il aimait
tous à l'abri du besoin au fond oui
c'était quelques acquis et quand il est
parti à l'essai
n'a pas laissé les gens dans le besoin
oui il a il avait pris le temps de faire
les choses comme il fallait y aurait
comme il souhaitait brassens jeanne et
joie c'est donc votre livre qui commence
les festivités puisque on va beaucoup
parler de georges brassens d'ici le mois
d'octobre
merci mme aline martin et
bonne chance pour la suite merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]